[موسيقى]
تحيه طيبه مشاهدينا
الكرام ماذا استفاد الشعب اليمني من ابعاد
الرئيس الم علي عبد الله صالح عن السلطه
وابقائه داخل
البلاد ليعيثوا امرات وتخريب
وفسادا الم يصبح وجوده خارج السلطه اخطر
منه
داخلها اليس بقاء الطغاه خارج السجن او
القبر هو الخطر
الحقيقي الا تشبه المطالبه باخراج علي عبد
الله صالح من اليمن المطالبه باخراج
السكين من الجسد
سد الم يتحول الرئيس اليمني السابق الى
خنجر مسموم في الجسد اليمني المريض
اصلا الم يتعاون مع اعداء بلاده لمجرد
الانتقام من
خصومه الم يساهم باحراق اليمن من اجل
اشعال سيجاره
انتقامه اليس الذين يطالبون باخراجه من
البلاد على
حق لكن في المقابل
الم تثبت تجارب الثورات العربيه ان
المشكله ليست ابدا في راس النظام فقط بل
في الدوله العميقه الم يهرب الرئيس
التونسي السابق الى الخارج لكن نظامه عاد
الى السلطه بقوه عبر دهاليز الدوله
المتغلغل في كل حدب وصوب الا يمكن للرئيس
المخلوع ان يمارس كل انواع التخريب من
الخارج فيما لو اضطر للخروج من من اليمن
اليست مشكله اليمن في جذر النظام لا في
راسه تماما مثل بقيه الدكتاتوريات العربيه
ثم اليس من الاجحاف المطالبه باخراج
الرئيس السابق من البلاد بينما يحظى
بشعبيه كبرى داخل اليمن الا ينتمي الى حزب
تضرب جذوره عميقه في الحياه السياسيه في
البلاد اسئله اطرحها على الهواء مباشره
هنا في الاستوديو على الكاتب وال محلل
السياسي اليمني الدكتور محمد جميح وعبر
الاقمار الصناعيه من جنيف على السيد ياسر
اليماني القيادي في حزب المؤتمر الشعبي
العام نبدا نقاش بعد
الفاصل اهلا بكم مره اخرى مشاهدينا الكرام
نحن معكم على الهواء مباشره في برنامج
الاتجاه المعاكس بامكانكم التصويت على
موضوع هذه الحلقه هل تؤيد ابعاد الرئيس
اليمني المخلوع علي عبد الله صالح خارج
البلاد
70.5 نعم
29.5 لا لو بدات بهذه النتيجه مع السيد
ياسر اليماني سيد يا سليماني ماذا ترى في
هذه النتيجه السواد الاعظم من هذه الشريحه
على الاقل ترى ان من الخطا الفادح ان يبقى
الرئيس المخلوع علي عبد الله صالح داخل
اليمن يا سيدي العزيز نحن لا نبالي بهذه
ال ما جاء في التصويت من قبل زملاء في
الجزيره الرئيس علي عبد الله صالح يحظى
بشعبيه في الشارع اليمني الرئيس علي عبد
الله صالح سلم السلطه سلميا الرئيس علي
عبد الله صالح اوجد امن واستقرار في البلد
الرئيس علي عبد الله صالح مد يده لخصومه
الرئيس علي عبد الله صالح حقق ما لم يحققه
رئيس عربي واي رئيس يمني علي عبد الله
صالح باقي ببقاء الشعب اليمني اذا اراد
العملاء والخونه من امثال هادي وغيره من
من المرتزقه ان يخرجوا الرئيس الصالح
فليخرج
26 مليون يمني نحن نقول هنا علينا ان ان
ان نسمي الاسماء بمسمياتها يا استاذ فيصل
يجب ان يفهم الشعب اليمني ويجب ان يفهم
شقان في مجلس التعاون الخليجي ما الذي
يدور داخل اليمن ويجب ان نبتعد عن التضليل
الاعلامي تلفيق التهم للرئيس علي عبد الله
صالح وتلفيق التهم للمؤتمر الشعبي العام
عبد ربا منصور هادي اراد ان يتخلص من
خصومه اراد ان يتخلص من اللواء علي محسن
الاحمر اراد ان يتخلص من الشيخ الاحمر
اراد ان يتخلص من الرئيس علي عبد الله
صالح عبد ربى منصور هادي بعث بمندوب الى
السيد حسن نصر الله الى لبنان في يناير
عام 2013 للتفاوض على تسليم الشمال وعلى
ان يستلم هو الجنوب وان يذهب الى الجنوب
وان يحول الشمال الذي احتضنونا
ووصلوه رئيسا ان يحوله الى جحيم والى
اقتتال وان يقتل بين اهله سواء في الاصلاح
نحن هنا اليوم ندافع عن وطن ليس عن الرئيس
صالح فقط ندافع عن كل الشخصيات الوطنيه
سواء في المؤتمر او في الاصلاح او في
الناصري او في
الاشتراكي عندما ارسل من دوبيه الاخ عبد
ربى منصور هادي الى السيد حسن نصر الله
ذهب من دوبيه الاخ محمد الشدادي نائب رئيس
مجلس النواب واللواء حسين عرب عضو مجلس
الشورى وبعثهم الى السيد حسن نصر الله
وكان هو الوسيطه بين ايران وبين السيد عبد
رب منصور هادي على ان يتم ازاحه كل من
الرئيس علي عبد الله صالح بالقتل او
بالتصفيه واللواء علي محسن بالقتل او
بالتصفيه كما صفى القشيبي من قبل وتصفيه
كذلك الشيخ حميد الاحمر نحن نريد ان نفضح
المؤامره التي يقودها هادي والحوثي بتنفيذ
المشروع الايراني داخل اليمن يا استاذ
فيصل انا ساقول كلام امام الله عز وجل
وانا مسؤول امام هذا الشعب ان اقول كلام
وانا مسؤول للمحاكمه والمساله ساختصر عبد
الربى منصور هادي بعث المندوبين لحسن نصر
الله وبعد اسبو جاه الرد وتم النقاش
والاتفاق من الايرانيين وقدمت 3 مليار
استلم منها جلال هادي 500 مليون داخل
اديسا ابابا من مندوب الحرس الثوري وبعد
ذلك انشاءات قرف عمليات في داخل صنعاء في
الامن القومي وفي جهاز الامن السياسي كان
يتراس هذه العمليات باشراف هادي شخصيا ان
ينقل المعلومات عبد الملك الحوثي برئاسه
رئيس الجهاز الامن القومي علي حسن الاحمدي
ورئيس جهاز الامن السياسي جلال يشان قامت
هذه الغرفه وسهلت للحوثي طرد ابناء دماج و
وقتال ابناء دماج باسلاح الجيش اليمني
وبدعم الرئيس ووزير دفاع محمد ناصر طيب
وبعد ذلك اشرف على الاجتماع يا استاذ فيصل
يحيى الشامي اشرف على هذا باختصار عبد ربا
منصور دي سلم البلد يران ويدير مشروع
ايران ونحن نذهب لاتهامات الرئيس صالح
ونبتعد عن الهدف الحقيقي في تحقيق مشروع
ايران الذي اليوم يسير بقطاع الرئاسه
اليوم في هذه اللحظات الي انا اتحدث معك
الرئيس هذ مكن الحوثيين من محافظات حدوديه
لكي يهدد بهم اشقان في مجلس التعاون
الخليجي محافظه الحديده عند رغبه الحوثي
عين شخص حوثي في محافظه الحديده وشخص في
محافظه الجوف شخص في محافظه دمار ما كل
هذه نعم اشكرك جزيل الشكر كيف ترد على هذا
الكلام رمتني بدائها انسل تفضل طبعا انا
لست في صدد السجال لكن ينبغي ايضاح بعض
نقاط ال يعني حكايه انه هذه انا لا ادافع
عن هذه ان هذه في نهايه المطاف هو سليل
علي عبد الله صالح بنهايه المطاف هو نائب
الرئيس السابق علي عبد الله صالح وهو الان
هو الرئيس الحالي انا في تصوري الشخصي ان
الرجلين مسؤولان مسؤوليه تاريخيه عنما
التت اليه الاوضاع في اليمن ولكن لا ينبغي
ان ان نحصر في زاويه ان ان الذي يهاجم علي
عبد الله صالح يظهر على انه يدافع عن هذه
او العكس ن كلاهما احدهما سيئه الاخر انا
هذا هذا في تصوري كلاهما عمل الحوثي
وكلاهما خدم الحوثي وكلاهما ادخل الحوثي
على سبيل المثال الزميل العزيز الاخ ياسر
يقول ان هادي سلم الحديده لجماعه الحوثي
اريد ان اذكره وانا ابصم على ذلك بالعاشر
لكن اريد ان اذكره بان الذين اعضاء المجلس
المحلي الذين اختاروا المحافظ الحوثي
الجديد هم بكل اسف شديد التيار الحوثي
داخل المؤتمر الشعبي العام اقول قها بكل
اسف ف علي عبد الله صالح نعم لانني اصلا
اعز هذا الحزب وهو حزب قديم هوو الذي اتت
الوحده على يديه وعلى يدي الحزب الاشتراك
اليمني لكن ينبغي ان نشير بالبنان الى ان
هناك تيارا حوثيا داخل المؤتمر الشعبي
العام يرتبط بالحوثيين سلاليه ويرتبط
بالحوثيين مذهبيا وهو الذي ورط المؤتمر في
علاقه غير شرعيه مع الحوثيين وهو الذي
ايضا
ورط قيادات عسكريه مهمه محسوبه على
المؤتمر وهي في الجيش ودخلت ادخل الحوثيين
الى صنعاء ادخل الحوثيين الى عمران طبعا
في تصوري الشخصي الرئيس هذها رجل ضعيف هذه
مجمع عليها من قبل كل اليمنيين الرئيس هذه
رجل ضعيف علي عبد الله صالح رجل داهيه
وماكر والمكر والضعف سيئت لا يمكن ان تكون
حسنتين اجتمع المكر والضعف علينا في اليمن
فدخل الحوثيون وجد الحوثيون فراغا وملوا
الفراغ هذاك نشا من الخلاف الناشئ بين عبد
الله بو منصور هادي وبين علي عبد الله
صالح بين اللقاء المشترك وبين المؤتمر
الشعبي العام بين اللواء علي محسن الاحمر
وبين محمد ناصر احمد نحن بيع بلدنا واتفق
مع الاخ ياسر بيع بلدنا لايران لكن لا
ينبغي ان نتهم هذه دون ان نتهم علي عبد
الله صالح علي عبد الله صالح لا يزال
مؤثرا في السلطه ولا يزال لديه خيوط صحيح
انه خرج خارج السلطه لكن عن طريق المؤتمر
الشعبي العام يستطيع ان يلعب وعن طريق
علاقاته القبليه ايضا يستطيع ان يلعب وعن
طريق المال يستطيع ان يلعب وهناك شواهد
كثيره عندما ظرب ضربت الفرقه الاولى مدرعه
كانت تضرب من معسكرات الحارس الجمهوري في
الصباحه وعندما ضربت ايضا كانت والحوثيون
الذين حاصروا صنعاء حاصروها و خيموا امام
معسكرات ما كان يعرف سابقا باسم الحرس
الجمهوري سواء كان في السواد او في
الصباحه هذه حقائق ينبغي لمن يريد اخي
ياسر الكريم ينبغي لمن يريد ان يوصلها
للناس ينبغي ان يكون منصفا بان يقول ان
هذه شخص ضعيف وانه فعلا تحالف مع الحوثيين
لكن ايضا صالح تحالف مع الحوثيين وادخلهم
ايضا الى صنعاء والشيوخ القبليون في حاشد
والشيوخ القبليون في عمران والشيوخ
القبليون في صعده وفي بكيل هم منتمون الى
للاسف الشديد ي متم بصله صله قربه او بصله
علاقه حزبيه او بصله علاقه مصلحيه ايضا
بالرئيس السابق انا في تصوري الاثنان م
دانان والاثنان مخطئ والاثنان هم الذان
اوصلنا الى هذا الوضع ال الذي نحن فيه لا
يمكن ابدا ان نبرر ل علي عبد الله صالح ما
فعل بان الرئيس الحالي سيء انا في تصوري
في اليمن و وصلنا الى خيارات سيئه الرئيس
هاري سيء اس اسوا منه الرئيس علي عبد الله
صالح اسوا منهما الحوثيون اسوا منه صالح
واسوا منه الحوثي وهكذا حلقه مفرغه كل
واحد وكل طرف اسوا من الاخر خيارات عدميه
خيارات لكن الرجل يقول لك لكن الرجل يقول
لك بالعكس تماما يعني اذا اردتم ان تخرجوا
صالح من البلاد عليكم ان تخرجوا اكثر من
26 مليون يمني يقول لك الرجل هو قمه
الوطنيه يمثل الوطنيه اليمن
جذوره ضاربه في في في التراب اليمني والى
ما هنالك من هذا الكلام كيف ترد الرئيس
السابق لديه انصاره ولديه اتباعه هذه هذا
شيء مسلم به وانا لن انجر الى هذا المربع
هذا صحيح لكن بالمقابل هناك ايضا الملايين
الذين خرجوا وينبغي ان نعترف بهذا الذين
خرجوا يطالبون باسقاط نظام حكمه الذين
قالوا كفى 33 سنه وبالتالي فانه ينبغي لمن
اراد ان يكون موضوعيا في هذا الجانب ان
يذكر بان الرئيس السابق اجرم في حق البلد
اجرم في حق البلد عندما خرج من السلطه ولم
يدع الفرصه للنظام الحالي الجديد بان
يستمر لكن النظام الحالي كيف كيف لم يدع
كيف لم يدع لانه كان لا يزال يتحكم بنصف
الحكومه التي كانت مشكله من اللقاء
المشترك الرجل الان بلا بلا يعني بلا
مخالب سياسيه هذا صحيح هذا في التصور
العام الرجل بلا مخالب سياسيه لكن لديه
مخالب ماديه ولديه مخالب علاقات قبليه
ولديه ايضا مخالب في الجيش كل ذلك سيء لكن
هذا لا يبرر ان الرئيس عبد ربو منصور هادي
ايضا سيء
يعني انت باختصار يعني انت باختصار تريد
يعني من الخطا بالاصل يعني تريد ان تقول
ان نفصل صالح عن هذه او ان ندافع عن هذه
ضد صالح او العكس صحيح لانه لانه البيبسي
يختل كوكا كولا في اخ انا انا اقول صالح
خطا وهذه خطا والخطا لا يصنعان صح الخطان
خطئان خطا زائد خطا يساوي خطائين ما يساوي
صح وهما مخطئ لكن علينا عليهما ان نتدارك
اللحظه التاريخيه التي نمور فيهما عليهما
ان يتدارك علاقتهما مع الحوثيين المشكله
الان يا استاذ دكتور فيصل ان الحوثي اصبح
اصح الان مثل بلطج الحاره كل الناس كل
الاطراف في البلد بما فيهم الاخوان
المسلمين والتجمع الامن للاصلاح يريدون ان
يربطوا علاقه لانه اصبح هو القوه او في
تصور الناس هو القوه حزب الله في لبنان
مثل حزب الله في لبنان هو القوه المطلقه
ربما تصور الناس في اليمن وبالتالي صالح
ينسق مع الحوثيين لا يستطيع وان قال الاخ
ياسر انه لا ينسق هو على تنسيق تام لان
اعضاء المؤتمر الشعبي العام وقياداته في
اب هم الذين طبعوا شعارات الحوثيين ودخلوا
اب لان اعضاء المحافظه صعد اعضاء عفوا
اعضاء المجلس لحفه الحديده هم الذين
انتخبوا او عينوا المحافظ الجديد باز
الحوثيين على الرغم من ان وزير الاداره
المحليه قال هذا خطا قانوني انه غير غير
دستوري لا يمكن ابدا حصر الشواهد التي تدل
على ان الرئيس السابق طالع في الاحداث
وانه متحالف مع الحوثيين كما ان الرئيس
الحالي عبد ال منصور
هادي نائب الرئيس السابق وهو امتداد
النظام السابق وبالتالي اعتقد ان الخطا
الذي وقع فيه اليمنيون انهم اتوا اذهبوا
رئيسا ووضعوا نائبه مكانه جميل جدا كيف
ترد سيدي ياسر يعني باختصار شديد لا تحاول
يعني لا تحاول ان تدافع عن الرئيس المخلوع
بتقويم الخطا او تكويم اللوم اذا صح
التعبير على الرئيس هادي يعني اثنينهم من
بعض اذا صح التعبير ما في واحد يختلف عن
الثاني هذا امتداد للاخر كيف
ترد يا سيدي العزيز اولا الرد على الاستاذ
محمد انا احيي الاستاذ محمد جميح ومع
اعتذاري ان احي بدايه البرنامج بالنسه
بالنسبه لما اورده الاستاذ محمد جميح ان
من قصف الفرقه الاولى مدرع هو الحرس
الجمهوري نعم هو الحرس الجمهوري من هو
الحرس الجمهوري الذي قصف الفرقه الاولى من
الذي
انزل المدافع والدبابات من جبال صنعاء
بذيع الانقلاب اليس هادي الحرس الجمهوري
التي قصف الفرقه انا اتفق معك هو الذي
اشرف عليه نجل هادي ناصر هادي الذي هو
قائد الحرس الخاص لعبد ربا منصور هادي هو
من قصف التلفزيون دعما للحوثي هو من قصف
الفرقه الاولى مدرع عمل الحوثي هو من قصف
جامعه الايمان وعل نتذكر ماذا لو من رئيس
السفير الامريكي على الرئيس هادي من يقصف
الفرقه من يقصف جامعه الايمان من يقصف
التلفزيون من الحرس الجمهوري وحدات الحرس
لم تعد مسؤوليه احمد علي عبد الله صالح
الحرس الخاص الان عبد ربا منصور هادي
استلم الحرس الخاص واستلم الحرس الجمهوري
وهو مسؤول مسؤوليه مباشره امام الشعب
وامام الله ادى اليمين وادى القسم ولم
يوفي بشيء مما اداه لا حفظ اليمن ولا حفظ
الشعب ولا حفظ شيء في هذا البلد دمر كل
شيء نحن نقول هنا ان عبد ربا منصور هادي
هو من دعم الحوثي وهو غطاء اليوم للحوثي
في التوسع في كل المؤسسات العسكريه
والمدنيه عبد ربى منصور هادي اليوم كل
تاخير في بقاء في السلطه يمتد المشروع
الايراني الى كل اليمن هنا كي لا نذهب
بعيدا سيد ياسر كي لا نذهب بعيدا عن لب
الموضوع الا وهو خطر
استاذ فيصل لحظه لو سمحت ل لحظه لحظه
استاذ فيصل بس نحن يجب ان نتحدث بشيء مهم
في مصلحه البلد قبل الرئيس علي عبد الله
صالح اليمن تنهار اليوم يا استاذ فيصل
الشعب يقتله في الشوارع الناس يقتلوا امام
منازلهم المعسكرات تهاجم كل شيء في اليمن
انتهى لم يعد هناك لا استقرار سياسي ولا
استقرار امني ولا استقرار اقتصادي من الذي
اعطى الحوثي هذا الزخم كله اليس الخطه
الايران التي جاءت بوثيقه ايرانيه بدلا عن
مبادره اشقائنا في مجلس التعاون الخليجي
اليس من اعطى الزخم الشعبي لعبد الملك
الحوثي وميليشيات عبد الربا منصور هادي
عندما اصدر قرارا جمهوريا برفع المشتقات
النفطيه على الشعب اليمني ودعا الحوثي
جماهير الشعب انه جاء منقض عبد الربى
منصور هذه عندما ذهب وصدر قرار جمهوري لم
يعود لا لرئيس الوزراء ولم يعود لا لحكومه
الوفاق الوطني ولم يعد لاحد في الدوله صدر
قرار بتنسيق مع عبد الملك الحوثي وبعد
اسبوع من قراره يرسل مندوبه الشخصي والخاص
احمد عوض بن مبارك رئيس مدير مكتبه الشخصي
ليتفاوض على الحوثي ويفرش المخيمات من
داخل وزاره الدفاع وبدعم المعسكرات ومن
مال الدوله بدعم من هذه ليسقط حكومه
الوفاق الوطني ويسقط معها المبادره بسقوط
حكومه الوفاق برئاسه محمد سال المناظر
محمد سالم بن سندوه سقطت مبادره اشقائنا
في مجلس التعاون الخليجي وحلت محلها
مبادره ايران التي لم تذكر سطرا واحدا ان
هذا اتفاقيه السلم والشراكه جاءت وفقا
للمبادره انتهت المبادره الخليجيه حتى
يبقى هذه الى ما لا نهايه ويحكم اليمن
بقطاع ايراني ودعم ايراني وتخويف اشقائنا
من من القيادات الوطنيه القويه التي تتصدى
المشروع التامري على اليمن بس دقيقه شوي
سيد ياسر يعني انت بهذه الحاله تبر علي
عبد الله صالح وكانه حمل وديع يعني لم
يفعل شيئا تناسيت 33 عاما في السلطه
تناسيت الثوره ضد علي عبد الله صالح
تناسيت عمليات الانتقام تناسيت عمليات
الانتقام علي عبد الله صالح خرج البعض
يقول ان اكبر خطا اكبر خطا اقترفه
اليمنيون بانه تركوه تركوه داخل البلد مش
انه حرقوه اول مره لازم بس مش حرقوه لازم
كان يحاكم محاكمه ميدانيه من الخطا الفادح
هو الان يعبث باليمن هو ينتقم من اليمن كل
ذلك يتحالف مع الشياطين ضد اليمن وضد شعب
اليمن اسمعني استاذ فيصل استاذ فيصل هناك
رئيس هناك رئيس رئيس منتخب من الشعب
الفتره الانتقاليه لمده عامين عمل على
تسويف للمبادره عبد ربى منصور دي هو
الرئيس الجمهوريه هو القائد الاعلى للقوات
المسلحه انا اتحدا امامكم امام الشعب
اليمني ان يظهر علينا عبد الربى منصور
هادي ويقول هذا قائد اللواء وهذا قائد
المعسكر وهذا وزير الدفاع رفضوا اوامري
انا اتحداه لانه كان متواطئ مع الحوثي
بدخول صنعاء وقتل الشهيد حميد القشيبي
ونقله الى صعدا لقتله هناك لانه كان يريد
ان يتخلص منه قبل ان يتخلص من اللواء علي
محسن والشهيد والشهيد حميد القشيبي كان
يعني رجل غيورا على بلده وقاتل نحن
اختلفنا مع الاخوه في التجمع اليمني
لاصلاح لكن ستجمعنا مصلحه وطنيه هي اليمن
اليمن فوقنا جميعا اليوم الحوثي يتمدد في
اليمن طا رئاسي بقرارات رئاسيه الليله
الحوثي يتصدر ثلاث محافظات بقرارات
جمهوريه من عبد الرب منصور هادي عبد رب
منصور هادي ذهب الى عمران بعد سقوط عمران
في يوم يعني تشييع الشهيد حميد القشيبي
ليقول للعالم ويقول للخليج ان عمران تحت
حضيره الدوله بينما كان
هذا ناخذها نقطه نقطه ناخذها نقطه كيف ترد
الرجل يقول لك يعني لماذا التركيز يعني
لماذا حرف الانظار عن المشكله الاساس سيه
علي عبد الله صالح خرج من السلطه وانت
تقول ما زال مشاركا وحوث وكذا والرجل
امطرنا بوابل من من الاثبات الاثباتات
التي يعني عكس كل ذلك لعلك تستغرب اذا
وافقته على كل ما طرح فيما يخص الرئيس
هادي انا خلافي معه ان الرئيس هاه مسؤول
مسؤوليه دستوريه ومسؤوليه كبرى لانه رئيس
البلد لكن هو لا يريد ان يشرك صالح في
المسؤوليه وانا اقول لا ان علي عبد الله
صالح الرئيس سابق مسؤول مسؤوليه كامله
ايضا كهذه عما يحدث الان هذه هو الان
الغطاء السياسي للحوثيين وهذه استمراره
كارثه على البلد ينبغي ان يذهب ينبغي ان
لا يمدد له ينبغي ان لا يكون رئيس القائد
من اليمن هذه انهى انهى مستقبله السياسي
لا خلاف في ذلك هذه بتحالفه الان لكن هذه
ينبغي ان يقال ان هذه في حقيقه الامر هو
مضطر للتحالف مع الحوثييين بضعفه بحكم
ضعفه وبحكم انه استلم البلد كما يقول بلد
مهلهل وفكك ولم يستطع ان يعمل شيء لكن
بالمقابل انت استلمت بلدا كان بامكانك ان
ان ان تفعل شيئا كيف استطعت ان تقيل كبار
القيادات العسكريه المنتميه الى علي عبد
الله صالح ابن صالح واخ صالح وابناء شقيق
صالح يعني الان انت تدافع عن صالح بقه انا
لا ادافع عن صالح انما اقول بان عبد الربو
منصور هادي الذي استطاع ان يقيل كبار
القاده العسكريين الموالين لصالح لماذا لم
يستطع ان يقيل القيادات العسكريه الادنى
التي يقول عبد الرب منصور هادي بانها هي
التي تعرقله وبانها هي التي لم اسمع
الاوامر ولم تنفذوا بان الجيش لم ينفذ
لماذا لم يفعل ذلك عبد الرب منصور هذه
اخطا خطا تام وكامل لكن بالمقابل علي عبد
الله صالح ايضا علي عبد الله صالح ماذا
يفعل علي عبد الله صالح الان علي عبد الله
صالح دعا الى الى مصالحه وطنيه دعى الى
مبادره مصالحه وطنيه بعد كم يوم الرجل
يحاول ان ينقذ البلد الرجل عاد بطريقه
ايجابيه اذا اذا كان قد عاد هذا هو السؤال
الان هل سمعت عن عن مبادره المصالحه
الوطنيه التي طرحها صالح شوف كلهم دكتور
فيصل يدعون للمصالحه الوطنيه المجرمون
الفاسدون الذين سفكوا الدماء يطلعون
بنهايه نشره الاخبار في اليوم ويطالبون ب
مصالحه وطنيه الفاسدون في اليمن يدعون الى
مكافحه الفساد القتل المجرمون ال ارهابيون
يكافحون الارهاب نعم والقتل المجرمون
يدعون الى حفظ وعدم سبك الدم اليمني هذه
اشياء نحن لا تنطلي علينا علي عبد الله
صالح انا في تصوري ان عبد الله بن منصور
هادي اذا كان سيئه فهو سيئه علي عبد الله
صالح نحن لدينا للاسف الشديد طبقه سياسيه
مترهله سواء كانت من طرف هادي ام من طرف
صالح ام كانت من اللقاء المشترك والتجمع
الامن الاصلاح هذه الطبقه السياسيه
المترهله التي استطاع الحوثي ان يسوقها
ليله 21 سبتمبر عندما سقطت العاصمه
العربيه الرابعه حسب تعبير محمد رضا كازان
عضو مجلس البرلمان الايراني ساقهم سوق
العصا للاسف سوق العصا ادخلهم الى القصر
الرئاسي ووقعوا على اتفاق السلم والشراكه
اذلاء قالت الاخوان المسلمين وقالت
المؤتمر الشعبي العام وقاده اللقاء
المشترك وغيرهم من الناصرين وغير ذلك يعني
هذا وضع مزري هذا وضع لا ما كان ينبغي ان
يكون والرئيس هادي انا اقر ما قاله الاخ
ياسر ذهب سقطت عمران وذهب اليوم الثاني
ليقول لعمران للعالم ان عمران لم تسقط
وبعدها بيومين يقول لا ينبغي على الحوثين
ان يغادروا عمران يا رجل سقطت صنعاء وظهر
هادي هو الذي كان قبلها بيومين يقول البلد
تتعرض لم محاوله انقلاب وعندما سقطت صنعاء
قال لا صنعاء لم تسقط في المساء استقبل
هؤلاء الانقلابيين ووقع معهم اتفاق السلم
وشراكه ما يجري في اليمن شيء غير غير لا
يمكن تحليل بس ما يعني خلينا نربط الموضوع
بصالح وبقاء صالح يعني ماذا يستفيد
اليمنيون فيما لو ابعد صالح اخرج من
البلاد ماذا يستفيدون يعني هنا هنا السؤال
لماذا الكثير من اليمنيين لا هم لهم الا
اخراج صالح من البلاد انا في تصوري ان
صالح عندما غادر السلطه غادرها بنيه ان
يعود اليها بشكل او باخر والنقطه الاولى
التي وضعها صالح من اجل ان يعود الى
السلطه هي نقطه اقتراحه وهو اقتراحه هو
بان يكون نائبه رئيسا انتقاليا ونائبه هو
من المؤتمر الشعبي العام عبد الرب منصور
هادي وهو نائبه وكان بهذه الخطوه يامل بان
يظل عبد الرب ب منصور هادي مجرد نوع من
المحلل السياسي الذي يتيح لصالح العوده
مره اخرى واجهه للاسف الشديد عبد الرب
منصور دي اريد له ان يكون واجهه لنظام
صالح لكنه انته واجه ه لجماعه متمرده بشعه
طائفيه مذهبيه تقتل على الهويه و مليشياوي
ايضا هي جماعه الحوثي هذا قدر هادي لم يكن
اكثر من عنوان لم يكن اكثر من غطاء سياسي
سواء لصالح ام لجماعه الحوثيين لكن
المشكله ليست في هذا المشكله الان نحن
وياسر وغيرنا نتهاوش في الهواء والبلد
تضيع البلد يعني الان خاضعه لاحتلال
ايراني واضح البلد انتزعت من جسدها العربي
عاصمه البلد اليوم صنعاء اول عاصمه عربيه
ربما دمشق وصنعاء من اقدم العواصم العربيه
الان يراد لها ان تكون ايرانيه ونحن يعني
بين صالح وهادي يا سيدي الكريم انا في
تصوري للمشكل في اليمن ان ما يجري هو صراع
سياسي مقيه وبشع و على السلطه هذا الصراع
السياسي هو الذي انتج الواقع الذي نحن فيه
هذا الصراع السياسي دكتور فيصل يصدر لنا
على انه صراع يحمل طابع ديني يغلف بالدين
يغلف بالمذهب يغلف بالثوره يغلف بالوحده
كلهم بلا استثناء كلهم بلا استثناء وان
اراد سيماني ان يكون منصفا فعليه ان يقول
هذه الكلمه كلهم بلا استثناء مجرمون
اجرموا في حق هذا الشعب اجرموا في حق هذا
الوطن يعني كلهم متسارع على السلطه السلطه
وفي الاخير يطلع لك يقول
لك الطرف الفلاني هو الذي عرقل والطرف
العلاني هو الذي لا يريد ان ان تتم الامور
ونحن انما نضحي من اجل الشعب هل يمكن ان
نصدق ان علي عبد الله الصالح جلس في البلد
في السلطه 33 سنه من اجل مصلحه اليمن هل
يمكن ان نصدق انه هو ملاك اذا اذا كان
بهذا الشكل واذا كان بهذا الشكل لماذا لم
يخرج عندما قال الناس اخرج لم يخرج الا
بعد فتره هل يمكن ان نصدق ان عبد بن منصور
دي اليوم الذي يسعى بكل ما اوتي من قوه
حتى لو باع ما وجهه لايران والحوثيين من
اجل ان يبقى في السلطه هل يمكن ان نصدق ان
ان هادي يمكن ان يكون سعيه هذا لله
ولرسوله وللوطن ولوحده وللثوره وللجمهور
هذه مصطلحات ينبغي ان نتق من ترديدها
لانها اصبحت تقال لا لانها غير حق لا
لانها مقززه بذاتها وانما لان الذين
يرفعونها مقزز يا رج كرهونا حتى بالمذاهب
كرهونا بالثوره كرهوا الجنوبيين بالوحده
لان كل الجرائم تكون تحت هذه العنوان
العريضه والمجرمون الحقيقيون يتغلف بها
اذا ينبغي ان نسمي الاشياء بمسمياتها
لدينا طبقه سياسيه فاسده طبقه متاكله طبقه
اظن انها حكمت على نفسها بالموت سواء كانت
هذه الطبقه خارج السلطه او داخل السلطه
ولا ينبغي ابدا لاخي ياسر اليماني وهو صوت
جميل وانا اسمع منه اليوم صوتا جميلا
واداء رائعا لا ينبغي له الا ان يتحر قرر
تحررا كاملا من انتمائه الحزبي ليقول ان
علي عبد الله صالح شريك في جرائم الحوثيين
لانه هو الذي هيا لهم دخول صنعا عندما
دخلوا عمران كانت القوات المؤيده لنظام
علي عبد الله صالح هي التي دخلت المعسكر
الذي كان فيه الحوثيون الذي كان فيه
الشهيد القشيبي وعندما دخلوا ايضا صنعاء
كانت القوات المواليه علي عبد الله صالح
هي التي تقصف وان قال انه لم يعد هناك
احمد علي عبد الله صالح لم يعد على رئاسه
الحرس او قياده الحرس الجمهوري هذا صحيح
لكن هناك قيادات عسكريه ومشايخ قبائل
محسوبون لا يمكن ابدا ان ننكر ونحن نكذب
نكذب نكذب يعني مثل من ينكر الشمس يوضح
النهار عندما نقول ان حميد جليدان خلينا
نسميه بالاسم انه لم يكن مرتبطا بصالح
وانه ليس من قياده القبليه المحسوبه على
علي عبد الله صالح وهو الذي يسر وسهل مع
بعض القيادات في حاشد دخول حوثي الى حاشد
ومنها نكبت عمران ومن نكبه عمران نكبت
صنعاء هذه نقاط واضحه لا ينبغي ان نتغافل
عنها اما اذا اردنا ان نظل في مماحكات
حزبيه بين صالح وهذه فستنتهي الحلقه ب
جميل جدا كيف ترد سيد
ياسر يا استاذ محمد انا اتفق معك في كثير
من الاشياء وهناك في في بعض الملاحظات
التي اوردتها من ان الرئيس صالح ليس ملك
الرئيس صالح ليس ملك هو بشر وقال لمن لا
يخطى يا استاذ محمد هو حكم وكل نظام في
العالم لديه سلبيات في الحكم ولكن فتره
علي عبد الله صالح لم نرى القتال في
الشوارع لم نرى الاغتيالات لم نرى الفوضى
لم نرى الحروب اليوم نحن عبد الرب منصور
هادي يقودنا وايران الى الى الى حرب
طائفيه يريد ان يتحول الى مالكي جديد
لليمن يريد ان يبقى في السلطه يا اخي
الكريم 14 مليار لم تصل الحكومه اليمنيه
ولم تصل النظام السابق من عقدين 14 مليار
دولار لعلنا تابعنا الصحف الامريكيه منذ
اسبوع ماذا قالت في الثقب الاسود الهادي
ونجله جلال لقد ذهبت 14 مليار دولار يعني
قدمت مساعدات لليمن لم نرى منها شيئا على
الارض يا استاذ محمد وناتي نتحدث عن
الرئيس علي عبد الله صالح علي عبد الله
صالح لم يعد يمتلك قرار علي عبد الله صالح
رئيس حزب المؤتمر والمؤتمر اليوم خارج
السلطه لم نعد نحن لم لم نكون سببا في في
ان نخرج برع السلطه هذ والحوثي اخرجونا
برع واخرجوا الاصلاح واخرجوا الجميع
واستفردوا السلطه هذه والحوثي اليوم سيد
ياسر يعني انت انت تشير الى تقرير فورين
بوليسي الذي تحدث ان هادي بعثر 14 مليار
دولار في عام واحد وهو الامر الذي لم
يفعله صالح في ثلاثه عقود من حكمه هكذا من
20 نعم نعم بالضبط نعم هكذا اريد ان اقول
يا استاذ فيصل نصف هذه المبالغ دحرت الى
حسابات خاصه لنجله جلال ونجله ناصر نحن
نتحدث يجب ان ننتقد الفساد يا استاذ محمد
الوضع لم يتحمل اليمنيين اليوم ياكلوا من
الزبالات الوضع اليومي نهار هناك شبه يعني
سيناريو جديد عراقي لعل مهاجمه المحافظات
السنيه للبيضاء او لاب او لتعز من قبل
الحوثي وبقطر اسسي وللحديد لعل هذه بوادر
حرب طائفيه يقودنا اليها هذه يجب ان
يتدارك الامر لماذا لم تشرك اتفاقيه السلم
والشراكه انتخابات رئاسيه خلال سته اشهر
او خلال عام لماذا لم يتطرق اليه هذه ان
لم تكنون هناك صفقه بين هذه وعبد الملك
الحوثي وايران وحسن نصر الله ولعلنا
نستشهد ماذا خرج عليه نصر الله وهو يتحدث
عن اليمنيين وان نحن اقربي يا سيد
ياسر اسمعني لو سمحت يا استاذ فيصل اسمعني
تفضل تفضل نعم تفضل انا بس بدي اسالك
لماذا تحاول لماذا بس لماذا تحاول حتى
الان تبرئه علي عبد الله صالح من التامر
على اليمن او التامر حتى مع اعداء اليمن
على اليمن لاسباب انتقاميه انت تعلم انت
تعلم الحوثييون الحوثيون قتلوا من ابناء
الجيش ما يزيد عن 60,000 جندي في حكم علي
عبد الله صالح وهو يتحالف معهم اليوم
بطريقه او باخرى للانتقام من خصومه علي
عبد الله صالح لم يترك اليمن بحاله علي
عبد الله صالح يريد ان ينتقم من اليمن هذا
هو الشعور المتوفر لدى ملايين اليمنيين
الان بدليل هذا الاستفتاء لماذا لا تريد
لا ترد على هذه النقطه وبترجع لي بوطني
وما بعرف شو مصالحه وكذا ليس وطنيات انا
اتحدث عليك اتحدث معك وللمشاهدة
الرئيس علي عبد الله صالح يجب ان نقف امام
الوضع المتدهور في اليمن اليوم اخي العزيز
حسن نصر الله في خطاب الشهير عندما قال
نبارك القياده اليمنيه اليس هذا هناك
تنسيق يجري بين الحوثيين وحسن نصر الله
وعبد ربا منصور هادي عبد ربا اراد ان
يتخلص من خصوم الاقويا في البلد لتنفيذ
مشروع السياسي للبقاء في السلطه تخلص من
اللواء علي محسن وكان يريد ان يغدر
باللواء علي محسن ويقتله لولا تدخل
الشرفاء واخراج علي محسن من الفرقه في
الوقت المحدد اراد ان يقتل الشيخ حميد
اراد ان يصفي قيادات كثيره يقول في اتفاقه
مع الحوثي مع الايرانيين انه يريد ان يبني
دوله مدنيه بعيدا عن الخليج وبعيدا عن
المملكه العربيه السعوديه هذا اتفاق هذ مع
ايران واليوم الايرانيون على الارض
اليمنيه هناك خبراء من حزب الله وخبراء من
ايران على الاراضي اليمنيه هم من يقودون
الحوثيين ومن يخططون و يرفعون الوثائق
للحوثيين سواء اعلاميا او سياسيا وبعلم
هذه شخصيا من الذي افرج عن طاقم
السفينه الايرانيه جيهان من الذي افرج عن
اسرى حزب الله الذي موجودين في الامن
القومي اليس هذه من الذي افرج عن جماعه
الايرانيين اللي في عدن اليس توجيهات هذه
لدينا توجيهات خطيه هناك صفقه اسلحه كذلك
اهداها الرئيس بوتين الرئيس الروسي للرئيس
علي عبد الله صالح قبل مغادره السلطه وبعد
ذلك وجه الرئيس هادي الى عدن لماذا اسئله
كثيره وعجيبه يجب ان يفهمها الشعب الى اين
يقود هذه البلد هذه يريد ان يحول الى عراق
جديد والى حروب طائفيه اذا كان هناك وثائق
تدين الرئيس عليه عبد الله صالح فليقدم
عبد رب منصور هادي للشعب اليمني وللعالم
واذا كان هناك ضباط كما يقول انهم خانوه
عليه ان يعلهم امام الشعب ان لم يكن هو
الخائن اساسا وهو من سهل لدخول ايران الى
اليمن وتنفيذ ه المشروع لتهديد اشقائنا في
مجلس التعاون وتشرد من اليمن جميل جدا كيف
ترد على انصار علي عبد الله صالح عندما
يقولون ان الحل يعني الحل ان تعاملوا معه
كرقم صعب ومؤثر على الساحه السياسيه ان
كنتم واثقين من انكم قادرين على اللعب في
الساحه السياسيه لقد تم تجريد علي عبد
الله صالح من السلطه التي كنتم تدعون انه
يستخدمها لصالحه ويستغل مقدراتها اليوم
السلطه بايديكم وانتم تستغلون في لعبتكم
السياسيه فاجد استخدامها في لعبتكم
السياسيه اذا لم تكونوا قادرين على ملاعبه
الرئيس صالح فان ابعاده عن وطنه لن يزيده
الا قوه اما ممارسته للسياسه من خارج
الوطن فانها اصبحت عمليه اسهل مما تتصورون
ليس امامكم خيار اخر للممارسه او لممارسه
اللعبه السياسيه او اللعبه السياسيه سوى
التعامل مع كل الارقام في الساحه سواء
كانت صعبه او سهله هذا كلام صحيح هذا كلام
صحيح لكن دعني اشير الى بعض النقاط المهمه
يعني مساله لو لاحظت دكتور فيصل ولاحظ اخي
الكريم الاستاذ ياسر من هم الذين انتقم
منهم الحوثيون منذ ان اصبحوا رقما صعبا
ايوه انتقموا من بيت الشيخ عبد الله
الاحمر انتقموا من اللواء علي محسن الاحمر
انتقموا من رموز قبليين محسوبين على تيار
الاخوان المسلمين وتجمع اليمن للاصلاح او
بلغه اخرى محسوبين على ثوره 2011 فبراير
2011 لاحظ لاحظ ماذا اريد ان اقول الذي
حارب الحوثيين في صعده تمت الحروب وكان
رئيس الدوله علي عبد الله صالح بشكل نظري
يفترض ان يكون علي عبد الله صالح هو العدو
الاول للحوثيين يفترض ان الحوثيين عندما
يدخلون صنعاء اول ما يستهدفون يستهدفون
بيت علي عبد الله صالح وانا اكرر في كل
مره اننا لا نحرض على علي عبد الله صالح
بل ان المساس به جرم خارج اطار القانون
لكن ذهبوا بعيدا عن علي عبد الله صالح
وحرس بيته وممتلكاته وذهبوا يستهدفون رموز
ثوره 2011 ماذا يعني ذلك خصوم علي عبد
الله صالح يعني ذلك انهم يستهدفون خصوم
علي عبد الله صالح هذا مؤشر قوي على ان
الذي حرضهم على استهداف حميد الاحمر علي
عبد الله صالح وعلي محسن الاحمر الذي
حرضهم ايضا علي عبد الله صالح
وهكذا الشيء العجيب الشيء العجيب انا كنت
في برنامج تلفزيوني ايام الحروب مع
الحوثيين وكان هناك تصريح لحميد الاحمر
ضمن اطار اللقاء المشترك يندد فيه بالحرب
او الحروب الست على على صعده كان للقاء
المشترك موقف صارم وواضح من الحروب على
صعده كانوا ضد هذه الحروب ومع ذلك عندما
دخل الحوثيون استهدفوه هم مع انهم لم
يكونوا طرفا في هذه بشكل او باخر في هذه
الحروب لكنهم استهدفوه وذلك يعني ان علي
عبد الله صالح استخدم الحوثيين وتحالف
معهم من اجل تصفيه خصومه السياسيين الذين
انقلبوا عليه كما يقول في
2011 هذه نقطه مساله الفساد لا نباى بل
ابصم بال 20 اصبع ان كان لديه 20 اصبع بان
عبد الرب ب منصور هادي ضالع في الفساد
وهناك تقارير دوليه لكن ايضا علي عبد الله
الصالح لا يمكن ان نبرئ من الفساد علي عبد
الله صالح وصلنا في فترته الى درجه ان
الدول المانحه امتنعت عن تسليمنا كاش فلوس
لا ينبغي لا لا يمكن ان تعطينا لابد ان
تنفذ الدول المانحه مشاريعها بنفسها لانه
لم تعد لدى هذه الدول ثقه في نظام حكم
الرئيس السابق علي عبد الله صالح لكثره
الفساد بدليل ثروته الخياليه كما يقول
كلهم كلهم بثروه كلهم بثروه لكن اذا اردنا
ان ان نشخص الامور فلنقل ان علي عبد الله
صالح كون هائله وانه كان يلعب باموال
الدوله وانه كان استفاد منها واستفاد من
وظيفته الشخصيه وانه عين المحسوبين عليه
والمقربين منه وان هذه للاسف الشديد يسير
على نفس الطريقه الاشكال في التركيبه
المجتمع الاشكال في التركيبه القبليه
للمجتمع الاشكال في الثقافه التي تنتج هذه
القيادات التي لا يمكن ان تعتمد الا على
المقربين منها لا يمكن ان تعتمد على بناء
مؤسسي للدوله طيب خلينا بس لو اخذنا نقطه
الثقافه لو نقطه الثقافه يعني هذا اوجه
السؤال الى السيد ياسر اليماني بخصوص
الثقافه يعني انت الان تتحدث عن نتائج ولا
تعود الى اسباب ليس فقط اسباب المشكله بل
جذور الثقافه التي زرعها علي عبد الله
صالح والتي اودت باليمن الى ما هو عليه
الان يعني علي عبد الله صالح كما يقول بعض
اليمنيين ابان فتره حكمه حتى انه غير
مناهج الدراسه لصالحه ولصالح اسرته فيدرس
الصغار في الصفوف الابتدائيه في اليمن دون
وعي منهم انا احب احب ابي صالح انا احب
امي بلقيس انا احب اختي اروى انا احب اخي
احمد انا احب اخي خالد صالح وبلقيس واحمد
واروى وخالد كلهم ابناء علي عبد الله صالح
حتى ان الخبث وصل الى الى عقول التلاميذ
الى المدارس هذه هي الثقافه التي اوصلت
اليمن الى هنا وجاي تقول لي اياه يعني
لولا شوي بدك تقول لي يعنيك وحوله تفضل
استاذ فيصل استاذ فيصل هذه المعلومه هذه
يمكن رسل لك اياها واحد من من زمره
هذه هذا هذا التعليم هذا
التعليم يعلمه
حسن عبد الملك الحوثي في مدارسه في صعده
هات لي واحد وسال استاذ محمد قميح وتعلم
على وتتلمذ على مدارسه اليمنيه هل هذا
موجود في المناهج هذا غير موجود في
المناهج ولكن دعني اعود لاستاذ محمد عندما
قال ان ان الفساد فعلا في فساد نحن لا
ننكره كان في فساد مالي في فساد اداري كل
نظام لديه سلبيات ولكن دعنا نتحدث قليلا
14 مليار يا استاذ فيصل في عام واحد هل
يعقل 14 مليار ان ذهبت فليخرج عادي يقول
ان ذهبت هذه المليارات وان ذهبت الدعوم
الخليجيه اذا كان لا يوجد رئيس على مستوى
الوطن العربي في مدى التاريخ المعاصر يا
استاذ فيصل يطلب وصايه دوليه على شعبه
ويطلب فرض البند السابع على وطنه الا عبد
الربا منصور هادي هل قد رايت رئيس عربي او
ملك او امير يطالب بتنفيذ البند السابع
على بلده الا عبد الرب منصور هذه لم تحصل
تاريخيا لماذا كل هذا العداء اذا اردت ان
تتخلص من من من من خصومك السياسيين ليس
بالعالم كان يفترض عبد الربا منصور هادي
ان يكبل المشوار دخل مصر جاء محمد مرسي
وذهب وجاء بعده عدلي منصور وذهب واليوم
عبد الفتاح السيسي موجود وتونس جا
المرزوقي وذهب وجا رئيس اخر وعبد رب منصور
هذ خرجنا من ازمه الى ازمه ومن محنه الى
محنه ومن حرب الى حرب الى متى الشعب
اليمني لا يتحمل يا استاذ فيصل نحن نناشد
قاله الملك عبد
الله الي يتفهم الامر ان ان لا يتمكنوا
سيد ياسر موضوع الفساد ايضا تعود الى
موضوع الفساد انت تعلم لا حديث لليمنيين
الا عن ثروه علي عبد الله صالح الهائله لا
يتحدثون الا عن فساده الهائل لا يتحدثون
الا عن استخدامه المليارات التي قدسها في
تخريب اليمن الان والعبث باليمن الان حتى
ان البعض يتحدث في الماضي كيف جمع اخوه
تبرعات في اليمن من قوت الشعب اليمني من
اجل التبرع ببناء مدينه للشعب الفلسطيني
واللبناني في جنوب لبنان بعد حرب 2006 ثم
انه نهب الاموال لم يترك وسيله الا ونهب
فيها علي عبد الله صالح اليمنيون يقولون
يكفي البعض يقول في واقع الامر حتى علي
عبد الله صالح يجب ان لا يحاكم علي عبد
الله صالح س سيبقى خطيرا حتى في السجن كان
يجب على القضاء عليهم لا تقتلوا الافعى
وتتركوا ابنائها هكذا يقولون المشكله في
الشعب اليمني والمشكله في المبادره
الخليجيه بانهم ابقوا عليه ليعبث يعني لو
لم يكن موجودا لما وصل اليمن الى هنا لما
حصلت كل هذه المشاحنات المشكله في راس في
راس الافعى اللي كان مازال موجوده في
اليمن الان استاذ فيصل انت انت انت
استشهدت كثيرا بالرئيس علي عبد الله صالح
عندما سلم السلطه ولكن اليوم اراك منقلبا
لا يا سيدي مش مقل قبل شوي قلت له زلمه ما
في منه طيب تسالني تسالني طيب انا انا
متفق معك علي عبد الله صالح له انجازات
عظيمه في البلد وان اخطاء وان له سلبيات
ولكن اليوم البلد تنهار علي عبد الله صالح
لم يعد رئيسا قد بلق من الكبر عتيه علي
عبد الله صالح يريد ان ان يكون عامل مساعد
في خروج البلد من الازمه اليوم لم يتبقى
امامهم الا علي عبد الله صالح هو الحجر
العثره لتنفيذ مشروع هادي والحوثي
بالسيطره ايرانيه على اليمن علي عبد الله
صالح هو حليف لدول مجلس التعاون الخليجي
طيله 33 عام علي عبد الله صالح يريدون
يجدوا اليوم وقيعه وفجورا دخول وانتهاك
مساكن الشيخ حميد او اللواء علي محسن او
الشيخ صادق بتلك الصوره التي رايناها لا
يتقبلها اي يمني لا يتقبل ما يحصل اليوم
من دخول منازل المواطنين هناك مهاجمه هذه
البيوت والتصوير في قرف النوم ليس من
عادات وتقاليد اليمنيين يريدوا ان يوجدوا
هو ويريدوا ان يخلقوا صراع بين الرئيس
صالح والمؤتمر الشعبي من طرف ومن طرف اخر
بين التجمع اليمني الاصلاح لم يبقى الا
هؤلاء الحزبين القويين في اليمن يريدوا ان
يتخلصوا منهم هادي والحوثي باي طريقه كانت
وانا اقول هذا الكلام وانا مسؤول علي يا
استاذ فيصل نحن نقول يجب اليوم نطالب
جلاله الملك عبد الله بن عبد العزيز وولي
عهده وكل الاشقاء في مجلس التعاون الخليجي
الا يتركوا اليمن لايران ولمشروع ايران
يجب انقاذ اليمن اليمن ستصبح وباء على
المنطقه وليس على اليمنيين فقط اليوم
الدماء اليمنيه تسير في كل مكان على مرا
مسمع من العالم لماذا هذا الصمت نريد وقوف
جاد لمصلحه اليمنيين اليمنيين مشردين لا
نريد ان نعود الى سيناريو اخر كالعراق
وكسور يكفي دماء كيف ترد دعني اخدم اخدم
يعني الاخ ياسر بحكايه بلقيس واروى
للانصاف المناهج الدراسيه اليمنيه التي
درستها انا هي فيها ابي صالح امي بلقيس
اختي اروى وكذا لكنها بلقيس هي ملكه اليمن
ملكه سباء واروى هي اروى بنت احمد الصليحي
يعني للامانه يعني لكن دعنا نتجاوز هذه
هذه هذيه مجانيه لعلي عبد الله صالح لكن
غير كذا علي عبد الله
صالح يعني اتمنى ان يكون على نفس الخطاب
الذي يقوله ياسر اليماني لكنه مختلف تماما
علي عبد الله صالح هو يقول انه رقص على
رؤوس الثعابين وهو اليوم يراقص الثعابين
بلغه اخرى وبشكل اخر ويحاول ان يراقص
الثعابين نعم يراقص الثعابين وهذه هو يعتز
بها هو وقال انه رقص على رؤوس تعابن ورقص
عل على رؤوسها 33 سنه ا ا يا سيدي الكريم
علي عبد الله صالح في تحالفه مع الحوثيين
لا ينبغي ابدا ان يكون لدى اي من يشك في
ذلك هو الذي تحالف معهم باول امر وهذه
اكمل هذا التحالف الاشكال الذي حصل انهم
يتسابقون على التحالف مع الحوثي اتقاء لشع
على عكس ما يقوله ياسر تماما لا يعني لا
لا حقيقه ان علي عبد الله صالح تحالف معهم
عندما راى الرئيس هادي بان علي عبد الله
صالح استفاد من تحالفه مع الحوث
اراد ان يقطع الخط على الرئيس صالح
وبالتالي ذهب شوطا ابعد مما ذهب اليه
الرئيس صالح بالتحالف مع الحوثيين واوف
وفدا الى عمان والتقى بوفد ايراني في عمان
وحصل ما حصل وكان نتيجتها اطلاق سراح
الاسرى
او ربان السفينه او قبطان السفينه
الايرانيه انا في تصوري المصالحه مطلوبه
ولا بد منها لكن ينبغي ان تكون مصالحه دون
ان نضع هذه الشعارات دون ان يظهر ياسر
اليماني اخونا ياسر اليماني بالقول ان عبد
الرب بن منصور هادي هو الذي يتحمل الفساد
وحده هو الذي يتحمل المسؤوليه وحده وهو
الذي تحال مع الحوثيين وهو الذي انا ابصم
بالعشر على هذا الكلام لكن ايضا ينبغي ان
نقول علي عبد الله صالح ايضا ماذا تريدون
من علي عبد الله صالح هل اخطا الشعب
اليمني هل اخطات المبادره في ابقائه حيث
هو يعبث وينتقم بهذه الطريقه شوف كان
يفترض ان يكون لدينا نموذج جنوب افريقيا
وكان الناس يتحدثون عن هذا النموذج خرج
نيلسن مندلا من من السجن واتى بخصومه
وجعلهم في السلطه التنفيذيه وصارت البلد
الى ما صارت اليه الان جنوب افريقيا من
الدول المتقدمه بينما نحن في اليمن لاننا
لم نسر في هذا النموذج وانما كانت حكايه
المصالحه الوطنيه مجرد شعارات اعلاميه ليس
لها على ارض الواقع اي وجود صرنا ال ما
صرنا اليه يا رجل كنا في الحوار الوطني
نتحاور مع الحوثييين وهم كالافاعي وكانوا
الى جوارنا يضحكون ويقولون الدوله المدنيه
وال الفيدراليه والتعدديه والمشاركه
الوطنيه وكل كل هذه المصطلحات الحنانه
الطنانه الرنانه ثم لما انتهى الحوار
الوطني بداوا تدشير مشروعهم الايراني
بدخول دماج ومن دماج الى الخمري ومن خمر
الى عمران ومن عمران الى صنعاء وبعدها
ذمار واب ونزلوا الى الحديده انا في تصوري
الاشكال الموجود الان كل هذه السلطه او
هذه الطبخه السياسيه او هذه الطبقه
السياسيه هي التي صنعته وفي تصوري ربما
اكون مخطئا ان الذين انتجوا هذه الازمات
لا يستطيعون ان ينتجوا الحل لانه هم الذي
صنعوها لابد بهذه الص طيب ماذا تفعل بهم
باختصار شديد انتهى الو ماذا تفعل بعلي
عبد الله صالح وهو لب المشكله الان هو لب
الح ع الله صالح علي عبد الله صح عليه ان
يظهر للناس ان يفض تحالفه الذي لا يستطيع
ان ينكره مع الحوثيين عليه ان ينسق مع هذه
عليه ان ينسق مع الجنرال الاحمر عليه ان
نسق ايضا مع التجمع اليمني للاصلاح نحن
عدونا ايران علي عبد الله صالح ليس عدوا
لنا هذه ليس عدوا لنا هؤلاء مغفلون علي
عبد الله صالح وهادي يعني يظنون انهم
اعداء لبعض هم كلهم في مركب واحد ستلتهم
ايران المركب ان لم يتعاونوا جميعا ضد هذا
العدوان الايراني وتدخل الفج البشع في
شؤوننا ما لم يتصالح الاصلاح مع المؤتمر
مع الرئيس هادي جناحا المؤتمر جناح هادي
وجناح صالح مع التجمع اليمني للاصلاح مع
الناصريين مع اللقاء المترك مع كل
القيادات العسكريه ضد المشروع الحوثي
الايراني اشكرك جزيل الشكر هل تؤيد ابعاد
الرئيس اليمني المخلوع علي عبد الله صالح
خارج البلاد 70.1 نعم 29.9 لا لم يبقى لنا
الا نشكر ضيفين عبر الاقمار الصناعيه من
جنيف السيد ياسر اليماني القيادي في حزب
المؤتمر الشعبي العام وهنا في الاستوديو
الكاتب والمحلل السياسي الدكتور محمد
جميح نلتقي مساء الثلاثاء المقبل فحتى ذك
الحين وفيصل قاسم يحييكم من الدوحه الى
اللقاء يعطيك العافيه
[موسيقى]
شكرا
h